hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in the second part of the
transcendental question in Emmanuel K
prola to any future metaphysics he is
going to to talk about principles that
is gunet of possible experience if
farang and he's already distinguished
between judgments of perception and
experience and talked about a number of
other important ideas for example pure
concepts of the understanding which are
brought in uh the judgments of
understanding to go beyond mirror
sensible experience as such and give us
something that can be a priori that can
be objectively valid that can be
Universal necessary whatever other way
we want to describe it now we're going
to refine that a little bit more with
this notion of principles and that is
going to give us what it is that he's
asking about and looking for in this
second part namely a pure Natural
Science so he begins uh section um here
we go uh 23 by talking about
judgments when considered merely as the
condition of the unification of given
representations in a Consciousness so
that's what a judgment is is doing right
it is unifying two things at least
typically two things we're saying I
judge that s is p right we're taking p
and we're taking s and we're putting
them together in certain ways and we've
got all these you know interesting um
ways of doing that that you find in The
Logical table of judgments and in the
transcendental table of the concepts of
the understanding a little bit earlier
in the work and also found in the
critique of pure reason so coming back
to this judgments when considered merely
as the condition of the unification
are rules reg in in German right so
rules tell us what to do they guide us
and this is a really important you know
idea for for Kant how do we in fact take
the things that we
experience and make sense of them
whether for ourselves in subjectively
valid uh judgments cognitions statements
propositions or for uh
Consciousness in general uh B Uber help
which is what gives us objectively valid
uh judgments so he says these rules so
far as they represent the unification as
necessary are a priori that's you know
basic stuff that's part of what it means
to be a priori independent of any
individual ual empirical experience and
so far as they cannot be deduced from
higher rules are principles this is a
very important Point that he's making so
we could have rules that could be
deduced from higher rules and those
would not be principles we're interested
in those that are at sort of the highest
level of generality and are not being
determined by other rules giving us some
sort of you know logical Bedrock you
could
say so he says in regard to the
possibility of
experience no conditions of judgments of
experience are higher than those which
bring the phenomena according to the
different form of their intuition under
pure concepts of the understanding right
F and render the empirical judgments
judgments about what we're experiencing
objectively valid and so he says these
are therefore the op
priori
principles of not just the experience
that we have all possible experience so
if we can figure out what these are we
are really in good shape as far as
understanding how our mind works and
interacts with all the things that we
not only do experience but could
experience or anyone could experience we
get a generality a necessity to it and
so he says okay these principles of
possible
experience are then at the same time
universal laws of nature okay this is
what natural science pure natural
science is supposed to be
giving us that's what the discipline
itself is treating this whole world that
we experience within what are the laws
governing this world now you if you're
you know used to thinking about physics
you might be like well he's not talking
about gravity here or stuff like that no
Kant is going even further back you
could say and thinking about how can we
even
experience anything coherently and how
can We compare it to other people's
experience that's what the universal
laws of nature which are the principles
of possible experience uh which can be
cognized a
priori actually are and so he says thus
the problem in our second question how
is pure Natural Science possible is
solved why there is a
systematization he says putting
everything into one unified coherent
system the systematization which which
is required for the form of a science is
to be met with in Perfection you know
being brought to its fruition here
because um beyond the aor above
mentioned formal conditions of all
judgments in general and all rules in
general that are offered in logic no
others are possible so saying no others
are possible means that we have arrived
now at the only way that we can really
coherently look at these
matters says these constitute a logical
and a little bit later he's going to
call it a
transcendental system this is what we
need in order to have pure Natural
Science and then now he says one other
thing here in this paragraph finally the
principles by means of which all
appearances are subsumed under these
Concepts constitute now he uses another
qualifying term a
physiological system now when you hear
physiology you might think about the
human body right anatomy and
physiology he's using that term in a
somewhat different way so physio coming
from you know fousy the study of nature
the world that in which we experience
things in which change happens so not
just our bodies but the whole uh
universe everything that we could
experience right uh a physiolog logical
so The Logical is the you know
underlying structure of all of these
things a physiological system which he
calls a system of Nature and this
precedes all empirical cognition of
Nature and first makes it possible so
there's a priority here and and the
priority is of what we are uncovering
with these principles of possible
experience that are the universal laws
of nature they're there first that is
what makes it possible for us to
perceive and then judge and make sense
of our
experience and to you know view it in a
way that's not just subjectively valid
but objectively valid for all human
beings so he calls this the universal
and pure Natural Science then he's going
to have some you know fairly long
discussions about how this actually
applies and he talks about the first of
the physiological principles gataa
subsumes all appearances as intuitions
in space and time under the concept of
quantity there's actually going to be
four of these right because that's the
way Kant is working and these are going
to give us you know what we find in the
pure physiological table of the
universal principles of natural science
is the axioms of intuition intuition in
time and space can be subsumed under
quantity the second he says uh subsumes
the strictly empirical element what we
experience in our actual experience
sensation which denotes the real in
intuitions not directly under the
concept of quantity because sensation is
not an intuition that contains either
time or space though it puts the object
correspond to sensation in both space
and time and he's going to say after
going into some discussion about you
know darkness and you know
unconsciousness and all that that what
we're actually dealing with here is the
peculiar
quality of uh Sensation that is involved
right he says that the understanding can
anticipate Sensations they constitute
The Peculiar quality of empirical
representations or appearance is by
means of the principle that they have a
degree and so so far here this is all as
he says mathematical right because it
does involve some sort of uh numbering
even though it may not be just subsuming
things under
quantity then it gets even more
interesting with a view he says to these
things uh
existence
right we can go um a little
further on and what we find is their
determination is not mathematical but
dynamical right so it's it's changing in
in other ways and he says this could
never be objectively valid in friter
experience if it does not come under op
priori principles which is what we're
dealing with here fortunately it does
come under them appearances must be
subsumed under now here we get to sort
of you know metaphysical ideas
substance cause and
effect and what he's going to call
community so substance concept of the
thing is the foundation of all
determination of existence or so long as
a succession is found among appearances
then we have cause lastly so far as
coexistence is to be known objectively
that is by a judgment of experience
under the concept of community action
and reaction and so he says thus a prior
principles form the basis of objectively
valid though empirical judgments that is
the possibility of experience so far as
it must connect objects as existing in
nature so let's pause here for a second
so we've got intuitions in time and
space quantity right um time and space
forms of intuition pure intuitions as
well then we have uh we're getting a
little bit more rich and concrete with
our experience we have
sensation of things that's qualitative
not merely quantitative then we bring in
the big guns you could say substance
causality Community we're connecting
things together right what about this
fourth one so then he goes on and he
says finally the cognition of the
agreement and connection not only of
appearances among themselves in
experience but in their of their
relation to experience in general
belongs to judgments of experience okay
that we've had those already and he says
this relation contains either their
agreement with the formal conditions
which the understanding cognizes or
their coherence with the material of the
senses and perception
or combines both into one concept and
consequently contains
possibility actuality and necessity
according to universal laws of nature
this would constitute the physiological
doctrine of method so distinction he
says between truth and hypothesis and
the bounds of the reliability of
hypothesis and so he's going to refer
here to the third third table of
principles drawn from the nature of the
understanding itself according to the
critical method K critical method that
is shows an inherent Perfection which
raises it far above every other table
that has been tried and we're going to
talk about those later on like for
example Aristotle's categories there's a
little section on that towards the end
of this K saying I have finally
uncovered for us all of the possible
principles of possible experience and
they're here in a system in these nice
tables where things correspond to each
other and you can wrap your head around
it now he talks about uh two other
things in this section before we get to
looking at how this would say apply to
Hume so one of these is that he says
that all of these synthetic AR prior
principles can be brought under one
single AR priori principle namely that
of the faculty of judging in general
which constitutes the essence of
experience as regards the understanding
we can be certain there are no more such
principles so this is really quite nice
right now he he also wants to clarify
for us that this does not apply to the
things in themselves this is a point
that he's already made several different
times this you know examination this
this
transcendental uh analysis of the
understanding and how it works what it
does in judgment in
cognition this is not supposed to be
about the Numa as he's going to call it
later the things in themselves and he'll
clarify here that um for example I do
not say things in themselves possess a
quantity that their reality possesses a
degree their existence a connection of
accidents and a substance nobody can
prove this because uh without any
reference to sensuous Intuition or a
connection of this intuition in a
possible experience it's absolutely
possible we can't get at the things in
themselves through this but that's okay
we don't need to what we're doing here
is looking at any possible experience
that we're having and what are the laws
the rules the principles that govern
that not just for you or me but for all
human beings potentially all rational
beings right and he's going to talk
about um proving these princi principles
um he tells us more about the mode of
proof of these principles and he says
You must pay attention to this which
occurs under the title of analogies of
experience those don't refer to the
generation of intuition but to the
connection of their existence in
experience and this can be nothing but
the determination of their existence in
time according to necessary laws under
which the connection is objectively
valid and thus becomes experience now
you know talking about proof here might
lead you to think that he's going to
give you a nice argument for this and
it's that's not the way that Kant is
proving this Kant is essentially saying
listen the proof is in the principles
the proof is in the system that I'm
laying out for you as the only possible
system you want to think of some other
one go ahead see if it doesn't fall
under these principles right so that is
the kind of of proof that he's carrying
out here there's longer discussions of
these of course in the critique of pure
reason but that takes us beyond the
proma to any future metaphysics and now
Khan thinks that since we have these the
complete set of the principles of all
possible experience we have what we need
for Pure Natural Science and now it's a
matter of explaining some of the other
issues or CL verifying matters that
arise